roll camera rolling my name is George
Mouse and it's my job to celebrate the
regional American hamburger there's not
just one style of hamburger there's
actually many different styles and many
different regions airplane of course as
you move across America burger diversity
of pounds there's so much to know and
learn about the American hamburger out
there so you know what let's go to Texas
what's my hailed a Bob Ross today okay
so today I'm gonna make for you a hyper
regional burger the smoked burger you
think about the way a burger is normally
cooked it's usually cooked on a flattop
something that takes about five minutes
smoking usually takes a long time Texas
seems to me to be the center of beef
smoking beef sausage beef rib beef
brisket so it makes sense that my first
smoked burner was in Texas land again
whoa oh [ __ ] that come from
a smoker burger what I've done here I've
taken a classic backyard kettle grill
and I set it up for off set smoking
which basically means that I've got
coals on one side I'm gonna put the
burgers on the other side I use a
chimney starter for igniting the coals
lighter fluid is gross don't use it it
actually makes your food taste like
lighter fluid yeah what do you want that
I have formed patties by myself using a
ring actual dough cutting ring to make
these perfectly round patties it's very
important because you want to make sure
when you grill or smoke burgers that you
have a nice edge on the burger you
wanted to stand roughly 5 6 ounce
patties I'm gonna position one of my
grill grate holes over the coals do you
hear that no you don't hear it because
there's no sizzle this is gonna sit here
and smoke you want to know how long 50
minutes salt is key salt is just gonna
melt into the burger it's not even gonna
really cook it's just gonna melt
I have offset coals I place the burgers
over the grill grate where there's
nothing underneath except air right now
the wood chips I use are mellow I don't
use hickory and Mesquite you're much
better off using apple or elder woods
you don't want to overwhelm the flavor
of smoke you definitely want to make
sure you position your thermometer over
the meat not over the flame if you start
to notice that your temperatures
dropping below 225 all you have to do is
open up this little vent the top oh [ __ ]
which could be hot be careful and
what'll happen is air will flow through
get the coals going again and it'll
bring the temperature back up again with
temperatures back up again close your
grade again that's all I have to do the
key though is to make sure you keep the
smoke inside this thing and monitor it
and time it for 50 minutes 5o 50 minutes
50 minutes 50 minutes I have learned so
many different ways to make a burger
poached deep-fried smashed on a flattop
you name it just another method but when
you think about smoking you think about
standing around waiting waiting for that
big moment to reveal the amazing meat
you've been cooking for sometimes half a
day so really do it we're applying the
rules of barbecue smoke to a burger
which is very unique it's a nice weight
across the two worlds I mean I right now
I really that smoke makes you want to
grab a beer or three
it doesn't it and sit around and watch
this thing cook exactly we're doing it
Mac she makes you slow down
well time you cook burgers it's it's
it's a lot of work a lot of work
happening and it's a very short amount
of time this is much lower this is you
know sit down and smell the smoke we're
about halfway through right now so I'm
gonna go ahead and check the wood chips
and flip the burgers I'm reloading
because I want some more smoke in there
I'm not gonna feed you bird go [ __ ]
yourself
we're rolling bird here we go 50 minutes
for ready oh look at those oh yeah 50
minutes that's what you get I only put
three things at a smoked burger on a
very uncomplicated squishy roll
untoasted even first a slice of raw
onion in the bottom to protect the
bottom second and put the patty o next
to it with the pickles on dill pickle
slices there's so much sweetness in your
barbecue sauce that you want to be able
to balance that with a good dill pickle
slice and then barbecue sauce any kind
of barbecue sauce uncomplicated very
Texan and smoked it's a smoked burger
mmm smoke ring
mmm-hmm well good I've done a lot of
hamburger research over the years the
largest number of hamburger joints in my
book hamburger America or in Texas
because it's a very burger proud state
I'm very proud of this burger smokey see
you next time
[Music]
[Laughter]